like I say you can have practically
anything you want in life but you can't
have everything you want in life so that
means you have to prioritize what are
the things you're going after that has
to do with the earlier part of you know
know what you're going after that
matches your nature to the the path okay
be clear do you know that as after I or
maybe you're discovering it but make
sure you discover it then when you get
there you will encounter your obstacles
and problems they will surface so you
pause and you say okay that's a problem
it's an obstacle and you work with
somebody who's got a personality who
will and and you appreciate their work
either to help maybe they do some of
those things for you that need to be
done or maybe they help keep you on
track or something then you will have a
design that will work
and then if you take that design so many
people form designs but they don't
follow through and don't do it so step
number five is do it okay do it and then
you do this on an ongoing basis that's
why I have these Loops you know you know
all the books and everything have these
Loops because that's what evolution is
like you you learn something and then it
starts to fail and you start to fail and
and then you reflect and then you learn
something and you do it differently and
then you go up to a new higher level